now with Trump political ideology has
become a little murkier and a little
less clear as well over here their
questions is he a populist is he a
conservative is he a secret Nazi Russian
KGB Manchurian Candidate all of the
above perhaps from my vantage last week
in the motherland perhaps the defining
feature of President Trump's political
vision came into view is respect for
American institutions and tradition his
traditionalism among all the calls to
topple Columbus statues and rename
Columbus Day Trump signed a proclamation
on Monday that said quote the permanent
arrival of Europeans to the Americas was
a transformative event that undeniably
and fundamentally changed the course of
human history and set the stage for the
development of our great nation
therefore on Columbus Day not indigenous
peoples day Columbus Day we honor the
skilled navigator and man of faith whose
courageous feet brought together
continents and has inspired countless
others to pursue their dreams and
convictions even in the face of extreme
doubt and tremendous adversity so it
this seems like a minor point the the
tradition of Columbus Day who were
honoring what day it is whatever but to
Trump it it's quite important because
it's about respect and in a an
understanding and absorption a living
through the institutions that have made
our country great and not merely
platitudes and and simple words and
phrases and ideas that do it
he's waiting vigorously on the issue of
NFL players not respecting traditions
like standing for the national anthem
and saluting the flag even his economic
policy of skepticism toward big
government and big business alike of
grand charitable gestures by
billionaires that look a lot like Donald
J Trump has echoes of the distributism
that was embraced by the 20th century
traditionalists like GK Chesterton and
TS Eliot among others speaking of Eliot
even Trump's constant use of highly
modern media like reality TV and Twitter
to propagate support for traditional
institutions reminds one of Eliot's use
of modernism to attack - attack
modernism rather and yes I think that is
the first time that Donald Trump has
ever been compared to TS Eliot president
Trump's take on patriotism might have
been written by Benjamin Disraeli the
British traditionalist and Prime
my minister who pioneered one nation
conservatism and one nation conservatism
posits that societies develop
organically that members within those
societies have obligations toward each
other and it emphasizes the pragmatism
the reality requires and insists the
patriotic devotion among other impulses
compelled a fortunate to take care of
the less fortunate when one part of
America hurts
we all heard and when one citizen
suffers and injustice we all suffer
together loyalty to our nation demands
loyalty to one another love for America
requires love for all of its people when
we open our hearts to patriotism there
is no room for prejudice no place for
bigotry and no tolerance for hate make
America great again is a beautiful
phrase it's why Reagan used it in the
first place the make America great again
it's simple
the language is Saxon its Curt its
evocative it's called a populist appeal
by the common knowledge of the political
commentary at but what have they ever
known the phrase isn't actually that
populist the phrase isn't do whatever
you want in America the phrase isn't
make america work for youuuu me me me
the phrases make America great again
it's a call to make use of the strong
institutions inherited by this country
and developed in this country to sustain
the life of a country whose organic
growth has produced the most just most
charitable most free nation in the
history of the world